all right let's talk a little football
and retirement nfl star eli manning is
out of work because for the first time
in 16 years
the father of four is at home during the
start of the nfl season
instead of quarterbacking the new york
giants
[Music]
eli here's what's weird it's the
beginning of the nfl season you google
your name and all you see is that eli
manning is selling his new jersey home
it is a little bizarre obviously uh no
more football
talk no more you know headlines i'm okay
with that they just want to talk about
uh a home or selling a house uh you know
i'm i'm okay i'm at peace with that hey
is this true
coach manning you're coaching your
daughter's basketball team
i found out when i'm a coach they
finally listen to a few things that i
say and they you know kind of do what
i'm asking them to do it's the only time
i get an hour
out of the week where they listen to me
the two-time super bowl champs
loving retirement but he still likes to
catch a good game with friends
not easy in a pandemic so we teamed up
with verizon media's yahoo sports
and their spokesperson eli for a virtual
twist to game day watch parties
using a brand new feature available to
all fans they've created something
called
watch together which is a an innovative
fan experience
where you can invite up to three friends
to co-watch
exclusively on your phone on the yahoo
sports app
live local and prime time games
available on the nfl app
and yahoo sports app how does it work
it's very easy you just download the
yahoo sports app on your phone
and right there you'll be able to watch
the live games
oh what a cat tough throw there by man
great throw great catch